[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning diagnosts
i'd like to start my presentation
uh as
mentioned before my name is andriy and
i'm working in government of ukraine and
i'm responsible for
fiber broadband reload
in ukraine
uh it is a great honor to be here
first of all
i am grateful uh for a conference
organization
and a telecom company for
this opportunity to tell you about how
ukrainian telecom market
works during the war in ukraine
on february 24th
my family woke up from
several horrific explosions
in small city near kiev
it is very difficult to put into words
how i explained my
seven old years daughter
why we have to leave our home
and uh
how i explain that
the sick dictator from russian decided
to destroy
the largest country in europe
every day every hour russian missiles
and rockets destroy our civilian
infrastructure
our schools
our hospitals our roads
our bridges and of course
energy and telecommunication
infrastructure
uh this
this
presentation i want to separate
on two parts
in the first part i will tell about our
goals and achievements before the war
and the second part of presentation i
will tell about realities
and
challenges of our telecommunication
market in ukraine during the war
as soon as uh our ministry was
established we said few goals
we set a goal to cover uh 95
of ukrainian households of rural
households by fiber optic networks by
2023
all our goals is based on european union
goals and
berk
recommendations all the above goals can
be achieved through full-scale
deployment of fiber optic networks in
the country
for increasing of level of broadband
coverage we made decision to connect all
social infrastructure facilities to the
fiber broadband
this is a large governmental project
which we called internet convention
before this project 77
of rural households was located in
settlements without fiber coverage
uh in general there are two cell more
than 2 000 operators in ukraine
this is a simplified scheme of this
project
a local community provided a public
procurement
and connect social infrastructure
facilities in the settlement without
fiber coverage
it means that after procurement all
local population were able to connect to
the fiber broadband
uh the first question is about budgeting
our team created a lot of efficient
mechanism for uh carry out of this
project
uh we have our team have developed an
algorithm for automatically calculating
the distance between
nearest fiber networks to the settlement
which will be connected
we allocated in this approach and based
on this data we allocated 20 million
euro to
our local communities for further
public procurements
all the processes were based on
paperless
approach
all league all legal processes were
implemented by uh fully digitally
without any paper excessive any
bureaucracy
all legal steps all based on electronic
forms with e-signature and
several online dashboards
where everyone was able to
check all information about this project
all data and all approaches
ukraine is a big country is as i
mentioned before is the biggest country
in europe
for
implementation of this project
we um
we established a position of chief
executive execution technical officers
in all regions of ukraine it's it's a
regional cdto uh which were
coordinated coordinators of the project
on the local level and for avoid
corruption we
approved by a governmental act a
standard contract which you use by all
communities and all operators during
this project
and
your efficient approaches
and
and all our mechanism
our goals are achieved
we increased
for six months we increased level of
broad fixed broadband coverage in rural
areas
uh in 13
3000 settlements were covered by fiber
for six months
uh 20 000 kilometers of fiber optic
networks
has been built
and 7 000 social infrastructure
facilities
were connected to fiber broadband
after internet subvention we achieved
one of the
highest level of fiber broadband
coverage in europe
it is 90 percent of rural households
were covered by fiber broadband
unfortunately
this achievement and data
were relevant before the war
before the russian full-scale scale
invasion of ukraine
today
is exactly three months
since the beginnings of war
for these three months
22
approximately 22
of our fiber networks in ukraine have
been damaged
or destroyed
it is a photos of
our cities
left photos from key region from bucha
from european
i think you know about these cities
and the right photo from
chernihev
you can see destroyed infrastructure
it is a left photo from barayanka city
and local operator
recover their network you can see
building
right photo it's office of this apple
operator in european city
also
mobile operators infrastructure
has been damaged you can see photo
after the war began after
our ministry of digital transformation
mikhail fedorov
asked spacex elon musk
to provide strolling to our country
uh as a large number of telecom
infrastructure of backbone network has
been destroyed and a lot of people
were left without any connection
we have received positive feedback as
you see into
from twitter
for the most efficient use of star links
we distributed a significant
number of star links between our
operators
they use these kits
as a source of traffic
a lot of backbone network has been
destroyed
and
starlink
was critical in locations
where where large amount of fiber optic
networks has been destroyed you can see
photo the left photo is a fixed operator
who repairing his network and the right
photos it's
mobile operators
in order to everyone to be aware of
mentioned information
uh and detailed data
we
this year our ministry in cooperation
with the telecom company and the ufo
digital project is developing a
broadband mapping system
the war is continuous the war is
continuous on the land
in the sky
and in the cyberspace
so
for stopping putin's
aggression
we must maintain
telecommunication infrastructure
and fiber networks
despite of efforts of our ministry of
our operators
a lot of networks
have been damaged
and our country
and our operators have not enough
resources to repair in the networks
we urgently need a
network equipment and a lot of fiber
object network for network recovery
for backbone network construction
one of the largest manufacturers in
ukraine has been destroyed by russian
missiles
every day we need a lot of cable for
repairing and for keeping our country
connected
that's all
it is my context
you can contact me if you uh if you're
ready to support us if you're ready to
help us if you already maybe do not
donate the cable or equipment
and
and
in accordance to
experience of
ukrainian bravery is stronger than bombs
thank you very much
thank you all the best to all of us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you